[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory
in today's video we're going to be
discussing harry potter
sirius black quidditch gringotts and a
flying broomstick
however we're not just going to be
talking about any old broomstick
we're going to be discussing the
firebolt where a muggle
may see a broom as an object that they
dread taking out of the closet
a wizard sees something much more
special an opportunity to fly
we hear a few different brooms
name-dropped throughout the books
and films the most notable reference to
abram
occurs in the beginning sequences of the
philosopher's stone
when hagrid first takes harry to diagon
alley when they walk past the broom shop
children are gawking at a brim through
the window whoa
look at it the new nimbus 2000 harry
overhears as he walks by
and while the nimbus 2000 was a
prominent brim of its time
it wasn't long before it was superseded
by a newer
better broom the firebolt the firebolt
was released in 1993
and it quickly became known as the best
one around of course
lucky harry eventually gets one a gift
from his godfather
sirius there is something i never got
around to telling you
during our brief meeting it was i who
sent you the firebolt
crookshanks took the order to the owl
office for me i used your name
but told them to take the gold from
gringott's vault number 711
my own please consider it as 13
birthdays worth of presents
from your godfather my question is how
on earth was sirius
able to use funds from his own vault to
pay for the brum
sure he gave written direction to take
the money out of his vault
7-eleven but how was that order ever
allowed to be processed
sirius black at this point in time was
still the most wanted wizard in britain
so surely a request to take money from
his vault
would have begun ringing alarm bells
right
why didn't gringotts question the
request why wasn't the ministry
notified that a request for funds from
sirius black's vault had been made
how was it possible that sirius was able
to purchase harry's prom
via third party why did gringotts pay
out
in fact there are a lot of unanswered
questions here
i think that the most logical answer for
all of this is that
a the ministry doesn't keep or isn't
able to keep tabs on gringotts activity
and b gringotts aren't necessarily
obligated to alert the ministry with
regards to
suspicious activity inside of the vaults
this is reinforced by quote from grip
hook in chapter 15 of the deathly
hallows the goblins revenge
what about you grip hook similar reasons
said the higher voiced goblin
gringotts is no longer under soul
control of my race
i recognize no master what this suggests
is that perhaps the goblins at gringotts
were not previously subjected or held
liable by wizarding law
this would mean that as i guessed they
are not compelled to share the knowledge
about sirius
to any third party including the
ministry of magic
gringotts is an impartial institution
they don't judge their clientele
they simply control the flow of gold in
and out this is why they hold the gold
and prized artifacts
of all kinds of dark witches wizards
including the lestranges
i think that as long as a customer of
gringotts is adhering to their own
institutional rules
then no eyebrows will be raised when it
comes to extraneous activity
and that's it for this video did you
ever think about this
let me know in the comment section below
until next time
remember the world isn't split into good
people
and death eaters
[Music]
you